now at five it is day three as election
week
continues the latest on where key states
stand right now and where the counting
continues
and we receive another election update
but we still do not know who is taking
nevada i'm john muller live reported
straight ahead
the trump campaign alleging widespread
voter fraud without providing any
evidence i'm david charns tonight new at
five o'clock the i-team taking a look at
how elections are secure
and one more day of record temperatures
before a dramatic
cool down we'll show you what's headed
our way all coming out
good evening the race for the white
house is banking on just a handful of
states where the ballot counting
continues thanks for joining us here at
five i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis nevada one of those states that
now plays a major role
on who will win the presidential
election all right so let's take a look
right now at where nevada stands with
what has been counted so far
joe biden is leading now by just a
little gosh
about 11 000 votes but of course
thousands of votes are still being
counted
the vote count between joe biden and
president trump in several
uncalled states continues to narrow it
really all comes down to the numbers at
this point and we're going to have a
more
in-depth look at those numbers coming up
a little bit later in this newscast
we do have more election coverage in a
moment as denise mentioned but first a
neighborhood evacuated as police
investigate an armed suspect barricaded
in a home
near decatur and cheyenne that's where
we find sasha loftus and sasha what
exactly can you tell us
right now brian there are a few details
available at this moment but police are
still trying to cope this suspect
out of his home we've heard several
flash bangs and a negotiator speaking
directly to the man inside who police
say is armed now police tell us he has
shot the gun at this point no one is
hurt he is reportedly
refusing again to come out of that home
police sources on scene tell 8 news now
that this is not a hostage situation
this suspect
is inside the home by himself but again
we have heard negotiators speaking to
him
since we got here trying to get him to
come out it doesn't look like they have
been successful
at this point this has been going on for
a while and neighbors say they worry
that it could continue
for a while longer as you said a few of
them are evacuated out of their homes
and this is
just really a quiet neighborhood so the
neighbors that aren't evacuated are
really standing by
and just out of their homes seeing what
is going to happen with this situation
but again no one hurt
no officers hurt no civilians hurt and
that suspect
is inside a home by himself he is armed
though according to police
we will of course stay out here at a
safe distance and bring you the latest
information as it develops both on air
and online
but for now reporting live in north las
vegas sasha loftis
8 news now all right sasha near
alexander and decatur thank you sasha
well the eyes of the nation so much
focus watching our state of nevada with
its six
very important electoral votes yeah
clark county uh certainly uh feeling the
pressure now to get the job
done a lot of critics are wondering
what's taking so long so now they're
having a daily briefing every morning at
10 a.m
to give us an update on their progress
joe moeller is live at voter central in
north las vegas tonight with an update
for us
joe definitely all eyes are on nevada
but this race is still too close to call
today here at the election center behind
us 51 thousand votes
were set to be counted now we won't find
out the results of those until tomorrow
morning in a press conference like
kirsten was just mentioning according to
the secretary of state 190
000 remain to be counted in nevada and
90 percent of those
are in clark county there is only a 12
000 vote difference
so it is a tight race mail ballots
continue to come in as well today the
registrar of voters
for clark county said he doesn't expect
to get the bulk of mail balance until
this weekend we're not concerned with
breeding as fast as we can
we are concerned with making sure that
we are accurate in what we report
because this is a very important
election in the state of nevada it may
make the decision for the president
a handful of voters who need to have
their id verified have been contacted
and have to do so by tomorrow at 5 p.m
mail ballots will continue to be counted
through november 12. they simply had to
be postmarked by the third to count
it is possible we won't know if the
stage will go blue or red for
a few days now outside of the press
conference that was happening here at
the election center earlier today
there were demonstrators a little upset
about not being able to get in for this
press conference but
these demonstrators have been lingering
through the night there's still a
handful maybe a dozen or so
still out here but a protest is planned
outside the election center
in an hour reporting live in north las
vegas joe mullen eight news now
it is unacceptable in this country to
have illegal
votes counted and that is what's
happening
in the state of nevada strong
accusations from the trump campaign as
they plan to file a federal lawsuit
against the state
and clark county republicans claim the
county is counting
thousands of illegal ballots but did not
present
evidence of widespread voter fraud
sources telling our 8 news now i-team
there is
no evidence of widespread fraud the
i-team's david charns joining us now
with more about this latest lawsuit
david so at five o'clock now this
lawsuit has yet to be filed now eight
hours
after that 9 a.m news conference let's
break it down here for you the trump
campaign
and state republicans allege 10 000
people who voted here in nevada
no longer live here they also say there
are votes that are using dead people's
names
and again an allegation here they say
there are voters who moved here inside
that 30-day
residency requirement window making them
ineligible to vote however
the campaign provided not one piece of
evidence
about any of these claims
they continue to count illegal
votes that is unacceptable
and it's giving legal people
a sense that the system is corrupt
there are two people who spoke at this
news conference this morning one was a
man who said he was from a conservative
media outlet
and he said he couldn't record the count
on election night and he was told to
leave when everything closed down
in the middle of the morning we tried to
track him down today but
could not find him the second person who
spoke was jill stokey now you may
remember
her we broke her story back on monday
she's legally blind and she showed us
the device she uses to help her see
she says when she went to go vote in
person she was told her mail-in ballot
had been
sent and the signatures matched but
stokey is adamant
that she did not vote as you heard her
just say there
and believes the ballot was stolen now
in today's news conference stokey
mentioned us here at channel 8 saying
that i had told her reid received emails
and calls about voting inconsistencies i
told stokey when i
interviewed her and the i-team has now
repeatedly reported
voter fraud is extremely rare and our
sources are telling us
there is no widespread coordinated
effort of voter fraud here
the i-team has reported over and over
there is no fraud in
nevada we've looked at the signature
verification process and we've told you
how those have to match as well there's
a machine that does that that's part of
the reason why this is taking so much
time
we also told you out of more than 7
million votes that have been now cast
in nevada elections since 2008 just
two votes out of more than 7 million are
known to have been cast illegally
and that was by the same person in 2008
and
2010 however remember this is the first
election now where
counties sent mail-in ballots to
everybody
even if they didn't want one that's 1.8
million
registered voters more next at six
o'clock i'm david charns 8 news now
david thanks for that meantime
democratic party chair william mccurdy
releasing a statement responding to that
lawsuit saying quote
as the voices of nevadans are finally
heard
trump and the nevada gop have no other
recourse than scare tactics and baseless
suits end quote so today nevada's
democratic attorney general uh talking
about aaron ford weighed in on how the
election has been handled so far
and also addressed concerns from voters
kate houston is on this story she joins
us now in our 8 news down newsroom with
what he had to say yes attorney general
ford spoke directly to voters during a
facebook live interview with battleborn
progress and he tried to reassure
nevadans that all of their votes
will be counted now throughout the
interview ford touched on
several different topics one issue
brought up was the time it's taking to
deliver
election results ford reminded voters
that many nevadans took advantage of the
vote by mail process
there are also many safeguards in place
to prevent fraud from happening
which means it could take longer to
receive results overall ford says
all evidence shows that nevada has
conducted a safe
fair and secure election i will leave
the
uh hysteria and the hapa and the
hyperbole to those who are attempting to
undermine
this process uh because uh you know
that's not what i'm here to do what i'm
going to do is to defend the process one
that is legal
lawful safe and secure and that's going
to guarantee the free lawful vote that
has been cast
is going to be counted attorney general
aaron ford went on to say
that politicians will not decide who
wins this election
it's the american voters who will decide
he wants the will of the people in
nevada to speak for itself
this conversation also touched on some
topics such as
the vote counting process and how
signatures are validated
reporting from the newsroom tonight kate
houston back to you
all right kate thank you so another warm
sunny day for november in fact so warm
apparently we broke another record high
but we do have some big changes right
coming for the weekend ted yeah
86 degrees wow it's november right i
know remember 84
was the previous record on this date set
back in 1980 we broke that today
72 is where we should be but otherwise
86
still not too bad at least we're not in
the 90s to hundreds right fire weather
warnings will begin tomorrow at 10
a.m this is a red flag warning and look
at the all areas here that it
encompasses the reason for that though
is the elevated fire danger due to the
low humidity and the strong winds we're
anticipating for tomorrow speaking of
winds there's also a wind advisory
begins at 10 a.m tomorrow
through saturday morning at 4 a.m for
these areas here in blue
there's also a lake wind advisory so not
a good day tomorrow
for any boating for sure here's how it
looks we're looking ahead for the
weather headlines we're going to talk
about all right windy friday through
sunday
a huge temperature drop by saturday and
then that record dry streak
could it actually end this weekend and
next week is going to feel a lot like
winter a lot to talk about i'm going to
break this all down for you and give the
timing of everything
all coming up in your most accurate
forecast
all right let's get up to date on the
coronavirus numbers nevada reports its
fourth highest single day
numbers with more than 1200 new cases
and 10 deaths
in the daily report the high numbers are
similar to the large cases reported back
in july the positivity rate is 11.7
percent
hospitalizations up by 44 today
clark county remains in the red on the
county criteria tracker
with 769 new cases and six
deaths reported the recovery rate has
gone down slightly since last week still
pretty high at 89.3 percent denise
all right and it's still ahead tonight
here at five o'clock the fight for the
white house is down to just a few states
our i-team's david charns breaking down
the numbers just ahead
plus we're also going to check in on how
wind resorts is recovering from the
pandemic
their quarter three earnings for you
when the valley's news leader returns
this portion
i guess
and welcome back america waiting for
official results as counting does
continue in multiple
pivotal battleground states and of
course nevada one of those states and
the longer the county takes
the more frustrated the president is
getting in a news conference just a
little bit more than an hour ago
he claimed the late ballots are illegal
and the election could be
stolen our i-team's david charns joining
us now with the breakdown of those
very vital electoral map and those votes
right so at four o'clock i
called them electoral points but they
are electoral votes
and keep in mind the reason that these
are coming in right now is these are
those mail-in votes we haven't voted
mail-in at this scale
100 million or or so mail-in ballots
ever so that's why we're seeing this lag
here in nevada you keep in mind we're
looking at those six electoral votes
biden right now leading by 11 000 but in
georgia
16 electoral votes either candidate
wants to win that president trump
leading right now by about 3 500 votes
we have blue in here for arizona for
vice president biden
that's 11 votes the reason why it's it's
there right now
this is really leading biden right now
the associated press has already called
this race we have not but it's it's
going in the biden direction right now
he's ahead by 62 000 votes to keep in
mind that's more of a point spread
than what he won in wisconsin and
michigan right now
i want to show you though the path to
victory for vice president biden
and president trump if vice president
biden picks up arizona which he
will likely do tonight or tomorrow and
picks up nevada where he is leading
he wins this thing another thing is that
if he wins pennsylvania just flat out
which could be called tonight or
tomorrow
he also wins it's a bit more difficult
right now for president trump with those
214 electoral votes
he'd need to win pennsylvania georgia in
north carolina
and then r6 electoral votes are sort of
like icing on the cake for him
but again this is where we stand you see
where we are and you can see a 264 with
arizona in there for biden those six
points for nevada
bring him to 270. that's why all eyes
are on us right now
thank you david doing a fantastic job
on our election coverage isn't he great
job charlize
he needs a nickname can't just go with
david all right live look outside right
now 81 degrees henderson 77 82 for north
las vegas winds remaining calm let's get
to some other neighborhoods here to show
you
78 for centennial hills 74 for summerlin
80 for aliante and the lakes coming in
81.
i got to tell you it's really
comfortable i mean it's not too bad it's
of course above average we're hitting
record territory but at least not 99 or
100 degrees right 85 green valley
rhodes ranch mountain's edge in the low
80s profit 77 boulder city 78
86 for laughlin so here's what we're
watching the much anticipated system
that's going to change up our weather
tomorrow
is right here and here's its front
already bringing some rainfall in the
pacific northwest from portland
all the way to eastern washington
spokane shower chances
increase with that system on saturday
but then we think the better chances are
going to be on
sunday and that includes mountain snow
too so this weekend could be a wet
weekend we know we're confident we're
going to get some wind cooler
temperatures but
shower chances are still on the light
side as far as
getting the rainfall here we'll keep our
eye on that monday and tuesday it's out
of here though so
here's your forecast overnight 63 by
morning
thicker cloud cover still remains this
evening with light west winds now
tomorrow
it will become windy okay blowing dust
probably a possibility tomorrow 85 are
high so still warm
still another record day we'll probably
tie that record set back in 1988.
look at your gusts up to 35 possibly up
to 40 in some locations
forecasted highs around the
neighborhoods take a look mid 80s for
tomorrow someone 82 83 centennial hills
mountains edge
84. outside the valley also warm
tomorrow pump at 81 83
for boulder sitting after that the
numbers tumble big time
by saturday a 25 degree temperature drop
look at that 61 on saturday
even cooler on sunday denise was
thinking about hiking on sunday
i'm not feeling denise really not no
showers and the temperature is going to
stay cool next week too
that's your most accurate forecast here
on 8 news now
since i've got the next story ted i'm
saying you should do that hike
all right just go put a couple jackets
on
win resorts released its third quarter
earnings and outlooks for the remainder
of the year
kirsten joyce listened in she's got the
results brian ceo matt manox says the
company is not going to sacrifice its
brand or culture to make an extra few
dollars while they have significantly
fewer staff some 7 400
fewer now than pre-coveted they're still
operating at a five-star level around
the globe
now their goal here in las vegas for the
interim is to make sure they continue to
break even or make money
some of the encouraging things they're
seeing is a greater share of the casino
segment
new domestic customers who were
previously lifers at competing hotel
casinos
are now spending their money at the win
they believe their safety protocols and
all their restaurants being open
have helped them take the market share
on the casino side
i believe we are gaining share on that
front
in october in las vegas we actually had
our best month we generated roughly 14
million of ebitda in october
we had a little bit of hold uh luck in
there maybe two million dollars
but overall it was it was a very good
month
now as everyone on the call knows uh
las vegas has uh seasonality and we're
coming in to the slow time
so covered cases are picking up in the
u.s obviously
and november december are quite slow in
las vegas and have been heavily reliant
on group
win has also increased its online sports
betting acquiring company out of the uk
and it has begun its u.s rollout by
signing market access deals in about
nine states so far
in the u.s with more on the way caesar's
also had its earnings call today we'll
have those details tonight at six denise
all right we'll still come here on the
valley's news leader preparing for the
annual walk to end alzheimer's
this year has been a tough one it's even
more important to let everybody know
that we're cheering for them the changes
for this year's walk and how you can
take part online just ahead here at 5.
yes enough said call ed
you're watching eight news now live at
five
the annual walk to end alzheimer's is
this saturday and like most fundraising
events during the pandemic the walk is
going virtual this year
even though plans have changed the goal
remaining the same to raise money to
eventually help see a world without
alzheimer's disease
good day las vegas meteorologist sherry
swentz talked to team members this
morning about the event
so we do want to walk our neighborhoods
decorate our neighborhoods i plan to
adorn my front yard with flowers and the
pennants
and just bring some awareness that we
haven't gone away
fighting for this disease you can
register for the walk which again is
this
saturday fundraising will continue
through the end of the year
so there is still time to help meet the
goals and programs for all that
important research
and brian we do have some changes to
programming tonight a special edition of
cbs news america decides is going to air
again from
seven to eight keeping an eye on all the
election results then young sheldon at
eight
followed by jeopardy that'll air at 10
and wheel of fortune at 10
30. and as we do continue the evening of
election day three
there are a handful of states that still
have not been called so we're going to
track those results as they start to
trickle in again this evening
8 news now as your local election
headquarters will keep you updated on
all the election results
as they come in both on air and online
at 8newsnow.com
and if you're ever looking for updates
on pennsylvania north carolina georgia
nevada of course arizona
all over on eight newsnow dot com always
being updated
and we'll keep you informed on air
online
thanks for joining us here at five we'll
have cbs evening news decks and we'll be
back at 6.